[Music]
American Key Supply presents the first
in-depth tutorial to help you be
successful in the field when picking and
then decoding locks with Ley twoin one
picks and
decoders our resident expert with Ley
tools Mahar Eid finally breaks it down
so you can gain proficiency and
confidence here we
go General tips
number one learn a little about your
lock first find out before getting on
site what kind of lock you'll be working
on and which tool you'll need also if
the lock is missing any wafers in any
positions and if the lock decodes in the
same direction as it was picked the best
way to find this information is by
looking in the new Ley 2in1 user guide
by Tony
odley
number two practice increase your
confidence by successfully picking and
decoding a few locks before doing it in
the field with customers staying over
your shoulder go to your local junkyard
and see if you can find some door locks
that will help you practice vws h66
BMW's two track h92 BMW for track h258
are some that are particularly useful
for practicing for the real world also
the leasy training Vice is very helpful
for practicing on any kind of
lock number three keep track of what
you're doing try to remember which wafer
picked in which direction this is
important information to remember when
it's time to decode the
lock number four use only genuine Ley
tools there are many imitators and
although they may look identical they
break easily and are not accurate making
picking and decoding more difficult
purchase your Ley tools only from actual
leasy distributors in your
country steps and rules for picking all
locks follow these same basic rules
while
picking number one insert the tool into
the
lock pull the slide back before
inserting move the slide all the way
back and center before inserting into
the
[Music]
lock make sure the tools fully inserted
if you are not feeling any spring
resistance for positions in either
direction or if both sides are blocked
chances are your tool is just not pushed
in all the
way
two determine which Wafers are on which
side cycle through the positions without
any turning tension to see where the
spring back is felt if you don't feel
any spring bag that's probably the wrong
direction
[Music]
number three turn towards either
direction like a residential lock
picking can be done in either direction
but One Direction will always be easier
than the other if you find picking is
difficult try changing
directions number four if it Springs one
depth it's picked leave it
alone springing back just one step is
how you know you've picked this wafer be
gentle if you push these too far it will
become overp picked and you will have to
start all
[Music]
over
number five if you can push it all the
way down and feel it Springs all depths
skip it and come back to it
[Music]
later number six if it stops and you
feel no spring push gently until it
clicks past and becomes
[Music]
picked if it's difficult to push do not
force it try releasing tension slowly
until it clicks
[Music]
number seven keep going through each
position until all Wafers are
[Music]
picked even for positions that you
determine were already picked keep
trying them again each time until the
plug
turns
number eight in most cases you will need
to add more turning pressure as each
position becomes
[Music]
picked
all
[Music]
right so first step after getting into
lock you want to make sure you kind of
have a general idea of where all the
Wafers are so uh with no
tension you want to uh just get a feel
for where everything is so eight is
going to be up there's nothing down
Seven's going to be up nothing
down six nothing
[Music]
up Springs
down five nothing
up five's
down Four's
up three is
up two is is
down one is down so we
know 78 are going to be up 5 six down
four and three are going to be up two
and one are going to be down
[Music]
so apply a little bit of
turning
pressure and
just very gently start picking that
one's very stiff so pick it until it
bounces when it bounces one depth like
this you know it's picked so you go on
to the next one Seven's going to be
up Seven's
picked six is
down it Springs the
full depths so come back to it later
five very gently you can see it's
already pick so it must be a very high
depth just leave it alone don't touch it
four
Bo this one might have to come back and
check on it
later
three
stiff pick it and now it Springs the
full depth so it come back to it later
two little stiff but picked
over now one is very stiff this is where
a lot of people break their tools to get
one to pick you want to let go a little
bit of tension here until
it
picks now it's picked probably want to
check on that one later too so go
through it all again Eight's
picked Seven's picked and each time you
pick you want to add just a little bit
more turning
pressure six still nothing come back
later five is still
picked four still picked
three is very
[Music]
stiff come back to a later now
two picked a little bit more turning
pressure one still
picked eight
picked
[Music]
seven Seven's now
picked
six picked a little bit more turning
pressure
five still
picked four is picked three
stiff two
stiff now picked one it's picked so now
should be only
one holding it away from
turning
oh there it
is now it's
picked rules for
decoding number one refer to the Lei
2in1 user guide by Tony odley to
determine if decoding is done in the
same or opposite direction as picking
the
lock in the h66 locks for example if you
pick the wafer by pushing upwards you
would decode that wafer by pushing
downwards in the opposite
direction number two push until it stops
and take a reading it does not require
heavy pressure to find your depth yes if
you push hard enough you can make it
read deeper but that's a wrong
reading
[Music]
and so
now you want to decode and for the
h266 we picked 8 and seven up and how we
know that there's a little
springing but uh you want to decode
down and so without any pressure on it
you can see it's about a
it's about a
three so then go to seven seven was
picked up so we decode down and it is a
[Music]
two six was picked down so we decode
up and it looks like a
two five was picked down so we decode up
and it looks like a
three actually Four
four was picked up we decode down and it
is dead on
three three was picked up decode down it
is a
one two was picked down decode up it's a
one one was picked down decode up it's a
three
things to be careful
of number one do not ever force a tool
it should not take much pressure to pick
each position too much force will break
the tip of your tool and the tips are
not replaceable not only will pushing
too hard break your tool but you won't
be able to make any money from your
customer be gentle with your
tool number two do not push too hard
while decoding the lock or you will bend
the tip of the
slide number three when removing the
tool from the lock go slowly and be
careful make sure the slide is centered
in the keyway before pulling out it's
very easy to break the tip of the slide
if you are not
[Music]
careful